calm but don't forget to smash the like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends yo let's talk
about this here censorship we have the
story from the guardian russia blocks
access to facebook and twitter oh man
it's good the move to block facebook and
twitter comes as the government passed a
bill that criminalizes fake reports
against the war
you know what's funny i'm not a fan of
censorship for the most part you know i
think it's obviously there's nuance here
censoring some stuff is important and
good like we talk about child abuse
criminal acts and stuff that's where the
sensors are really supposed to be like
okay that is crime like against children
and humanity get rid of it but um when i
see russia banning facebook and twitter
i get i feel like this kind of catharsis
of like i wish i wish just get rid of it
i know it's so i hate it so much but it
is truth be told twitter and facebook
are still pretty good despite all of the
bad and therein lies the real challenge
the ability for regular people to
actually have a voice even if they do
face censorship and that's why we resist
the censorship here because the power
granted to the people by these platforms
was good and now they're trying to take
it back because they realize they made a
mistake
well
i'm generally against censorship i
generally agree with what you just said
the only really kind of interesting
thing i don't know that it's even
directly connected to this the only
really interesting thing that i
think i tweeted this this morning i
think people got really mad about it is
that one of the utilities of facebook in
particular more than twitter but twitter
has this too is if if you have some
controversial narrative thing going on
some controversial activity whether it's
ukraine whether it's a virus whether
whatever it is
one epistemological tool to sound very
philosophical that's emerged in the past
few years is whatever facebook will ban
is probably true yes so if you want to
find out what's going on with ukraine or
with a virus or with the world economic
forum or whatever it is
or is it critical very siri you probably
need to just post some edgy stuff on
facebook and see what they ban you've
got to add a little bit of that age to
your impersonation like it talks like
this well i don't have any marbles in my
mouth i just drank an energy drink first
yeah you got to stuff your cheek with
like toilet paper or marble yeah i'm a
very excited
world economic forum i hear what you're
saying about the utility of facebook in
that sense it's also true of the fact
checkers that they're in bed with i
found them incredibly useful in the past
so what i remember there was one
instance about two years ago where i was
doing research on a video about the
scandal with biden's son
in ukraine and the investigator being
fired by joe biden effectively because
he said he would withhold aid to their
country and one of the fact checkers
that i found and i was looking up i
wanted to look up debunkings of this to
see how strong the argument against the
the potential for foul play was and the
response was well it's true that joe
biden told them to withhold the funding
for ukraine unless they fired this
prosecutor but that was the official
policy of the obama administration in
general it's like oh right because biden
had nothing to do the vice president of
the administration had nothing to do
with the policy of the obama
administration no no no but think about
that a few seconds
yes joe biden did try to push an illegal
quid pro quo but obama told him to do it
yeah so it's okay yeah it's like okay
well exactly
have done this and then it would have
been okay like because trump wanted it
to happen it's just hilarious because in
these fact checks they will always try
to use their best argument against
something which in a number of cases is
actually true and they reveal their hand
in doing so and so there is a lot of
utility there mostly false context
missing yeah yeah
we don't want you to believe it mostly
false is like my favorite partly true
because there's there was one instance
where in politifact there were two
quotes one was from trump and one was
from bernie and they were almost
verbatim identical and trump's was
mostly false and bernie's was mostly
true and it was something like trump
saying you know like inner city black
youth have a 51
unemployment rate and bernie said like
the same thing but bernie's was mostly
true and they're like well bernie does
get this wrong it is
while trump gets most of this wrong some
of it is along the lines of like who is
saying it defines if it's true or not
that's very disturbing true how do you
quantify truth like
you know when they say mostly peaceful
protest how do you quantify when it's
most i got it
yeah 93 percent peaceful yeah seven
percent fire
hilarious
and that's the thing well they used that
number as if it was some kind of own
like only seven percent of them are are
you insane this is a country of 330
million people and these these protests
are popping up everywhere even if it is
only seven percent that's insane it's
like the weather okay so this is the
misconception people have is when they
say
it's a 40
chance of rain they're not saying flip a
coin it might rain they're saying 40 of
the day might be rain i don't know if
that's true that's why i've heard like
people they've done these internet
arguments that's how you get to view the
93 to 7 thing with with blm they're not
saying of the 100 protests 93 were
peaceful they're saying of the 100
protests in all of that exactly seven
percent of the time was extreme violence
which again conflicts with that i've
cited on the show before which is uh
that 70
of major city police departments
reported officers being injured during
these protests and you're telling me
only seven percent of them were violent
i think in combat or in war most of the
time is not combat then you have a burst
of it very so probably less than seven
percent of the time a soldier even a
combat soldier is in combat uh seven
percent's a lot of time for for
destruction to be going on yeah i mean
uh that means there's like a good half
hour out of the protest notably a
violent protest yes smashing seven
percent of its [ __ ] like that or
burning down buildings it's not just
buildings you have to burn down
buildings specifically in a poor black
neighborhood for black lives matter just
like
that's right because insurance will take
care of it poor supporters because
insurance means anyone can destroy
anything for any reason this will be
fine we're talking about like if if you
believe the if you have faith in the
person then you believe what they're
saying and if trump says it you're like
nah he's lying i came across this
internet video last night of you know
eileen waranos you guys know this woman
is she was like a hitchhiker and she
carried a gun and killed seven guys that
had she was like i had a gun and if the
guys attacked me i would i would defend
myself and the cops knew it and they let
me keep killing eventually after seven
deaths in a year they arrested her and
put her to death death row so she gave
the speech she was taking all this meth
her skin's all ripped apart and she's
like i had to do it i had to do it and
you're like oh this evil woman you know
but then they deep fake christina
positsky's face on it christina p uh the
beautiful comedian and it's this
beautiful woman it's it's it's still
eileen's story but it's with a beautiful
face and you're like i understand why
you had a gun and why you were defending
yourself because when you see a
beautiful person saying it it has a
different meaning than an ugly person it
is terrifying to think that that that is
real it's on face it's on instagram this
guy brian monarch his page what is it to
do with or it's it's a deep fake of like
like you're saying biden says something
and everyone's like yeah and then trump
does it and they're like oh it's evil
right like well all of a sudden but the
me it's the same exact in this case it's
the exact brian monarch it's the exact
same voice it's her with a deep fake
image and it has a different meaning
it's very well and this is one of the
huge problems one of the many huge
problems with hollywood but they're
always casting extremely attractive
people even to do completely
reprehensible things scroll down so i
think it makes those things seem more
normal or likable to a lot of people
25 weeks ago is a while yeah it's been
up for a long time this is repressive
tolerance y'all of course i have to do
the stupid philosophy thing right so
1965
leader of the new left harbor uprising
upper right right repressive tolerance
you'll see
well this maybe you won't see but when
we do it trump and biden you will so and
you got to see this is this is the deep
thing yeah yeah i mean we'll
talk about this i don't i'm kind of
confused as to what we're talking about
once you see the video you'll know it's
three minutes it's her like basically on
death row and they're giving her a final
interview and she's like i've come to
peace with it you know you're all a
bunch of this and that and uh it's just
so bone chilling to see that same
sentiment with a beautiful face because
i was getting like
empathy i was like wow maybe she
shouldn't have been put to death right
so this is what's going on
the there's been a very i actually i
hate to maybe pin this on the guy
because i thought he was funny too but i
call this the jon stewart effect there's
been a relentless campaign for a very
long time to make conservatives bad ugly
and stupid to the general population so
trump is bad ugly and stupid by this
metric bernie is a leftist he's old he's
doing the best he can he's got the right
message but this is repressive tolerance
herbert marcus leading leftist or
marxist thinker of the 1960s writes an
essay 1965 called repressive tolerance
the argument and i kid you not i don't
exaggerate at all the thesis statement
of the argument is literally movements
from the left must be tolerated even
when their violent movements from the
right must not be extended tolerance at
all
and so this is why you see that
disparity we live in marcus's world we
live in the neo-marxist architecture
that this
guy created and he's very influential he
wrote a book in 64 called
one-dimensional man sold 300 000 copies
in the first year if i'm not mistaken
this stat might be it might be over its
lifetime but i think it was over the
first year
very influential widely credited as the
most influential leftist thinker so he
laid out an architecture where the
leftist line of thought is when we do it
it's good it must be tolerated and
anybody who doesn't tolerate us is a
fascist
if the right does it it's bad period it
must not be tolerated i i wasn't
exaggerating if we pulled up the essay
you could actually find the quote that
that is the thesis statement of the
essay movements from the left must be
extended tolerance movements from the
right must not be extended tolerance to
the point he says
do you prevent right-wing people from
even being able to form the thought in
other words he says this is censorship
and even pre-censorship which i'm not
even sure what pre-censorship is
so that the thought can't even enter
their head and this is the double
standard that we run into where you see
the mostly true mostly false for bernie
versus trump this is the double standard
that the left has erected and everybody
tries to point out oh they're hypocrites
other hypocrites and finally it's so
exciting for me to see it finally people
are catching on it's not hypocrisy it's
hierarchy they're actually asserting we
are better people than you we are
smarter people than you we are more
moral people than you and we are saner
people than you and therefore you have
to put up with all of our crap and we're
going to put up with literally none of
your crap and that's why you see that
dichotomy of mostly true mostly false
when it's literally the same statement
from trump and bernie this is why i uh i
get frustrated when i see like
joe rogan apologizing to these people
cannot apologize because
uh
when he did it only made things worse
yeah it made the story bigger and it
made the story more pronounced it made
the story last longer
and
you know what i love is i actually
really enjoy when they get triggered and
they flip out i've been trending again
so this is the craziest thing i was
trending for like i i i think i have
been
swatted more times than anyone else
in like this short of a period i have
been trending more and i'm like what am
i even doing it's really simple actually
i'm not calling anybody any slurs i'm
not insulting people but they're getting
extremely angry at me because i don't
care about them yeah and so when i when
i tweeted i tweeted i despise appeals to
emotion in response to a translator who
was crying talking about zelinski then
all of a sudden they come out and they
try making it out to be that i'm
insulting zielinski and i wasn't my
response was
because twitter put an editorial up on
the what's happening saying podcaster
tim poole blah blah blah i said i
drafted my formal apology to this tweet
wiped my ass with it and threw it in the
trash
and they got really mad about that
because
it's hierarchy right that's right
they're supposed to be able to tell me
that what i did was wrong and i just
laughed in their faces yeah and when you
do that it's the crying woejack npc meme
like
that's right that's right they get so
mad they they they start swatching rogan
should have either ignored it or made a
joke
and then moved on
i mean i i not to give the guy advice
but
my attitude is insult them and if they
counter insult them again and if they
counter keep insulting them and laughing
while you laugh while you do it that's
our twitter well into your point i mean
this is almost perfectly summarized by
aoc's quote that
she will be chastised
she'll be chastised for being factually
inaccurate when she's morally correct so
even when they say something which is
blatantly untrue it's okay because their
agenda is good and pure and to bring her
into it again
and bring it back to fact checkers there
was a hysterical example where she said
that she was in the main capitol
building
uh during the quote-unquote insurrection
and she was not
and
she didn't say she was in the capitol
building no she didn't no this story is
so much worse than i i'm surprised the
wright never caught this like i actually
uh briefly mentioned it to ben shapiro
and he was surprised he was like wow
nobody caught that
alexandria ocasio-cortez claimed that
while the insurrection was occurring
there was a bang on her door that's
right and they and a guy and she ran and
hit in the bathroom and then she heard a
voice where is she yes
that's what she did on her video and
then she was like this is it she thought
she was going to die
so i actually saw that and i started
looking at the time stamps and seeing
what was going on and then i said at
this time she was talking about this
this time there's people standing around
in the hallways of the congressional
building no one's worried what is she
talking about i had a huffington post
reporter tell me my timeline was wrong
and that i was actually showing video
from the bomb threat and i responded to
them that's the time frame that aoc
claimed the guy was knocking on her door
which would mean the guy knocked on her
door well before anyone breached the
capitol building and this guy from the
heavenly post was like oh yeah you're
right
hey how about that aoc made the whole
story up what it really was was a cop
knocked her door because the bomb scare
she was not afraid for her life nothing
had even happened no one had breached
any buildings nothing had happened she
made the whole thing up
yeah well there was uh there was um
when she said she was at so she had this
whole story
and i can't remember who it was pointed
out that it wasn't true she wasn't at
the capitol building at the time and
then the fact checker said she never
said she's at the capitol building okay
she never said she was at the capitol
building interesting she said she was in
her congressional office in a different
building and this was significant
because the fact checkers started saying
all the conservatives were wrong yeah
because she wasn't in the capitol
building and then for me i was like i
never said she was i watched her
instagram 45 minute video or whatever
and said she fabricated the story and i
laid out the timelines i'm surprised
that the conservatives didn't catch that
she fabricated that story they were
criticizing her saying eve she well but
she but you know she wasn't in the
capital but still it's an absurd story
and it was just like dude it's not like
reading an article till you see the word
you're looking for and then you stop
reading
as soon as you like get confirmation of
what you think you thought you wanted to
see then you're like i don't need to
research any further they were saying
that like she was claiming she was
scared but she wasn't even the capitol
building the fact checkers came out and
said yes but there are tunnels
connecting the capital to the
congressional offices so it's reasonable
that she would be scared the
insurrectionist made it there and then
my response was no it isn't her story
happened a full hour before anyone got
near the capitol building unless aoc
knew they were going to do it hey maybe
the feds should question her as to how
she knew they were going to be storming
in the building
maybe that's right thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there